ONE.
>> THEY HAD A FEW NASTY FACTS IN
THERE, I'M READY TO SLAM IT DOWN
THEIR THROAT.
BECAUSE WE HAVE AN 87 PAGE
REPORT WHICH WE WILL USE, AND
SOME THINGS THAT THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL DID THAT I THINK THEY
WON'T WANT PEOPLE TO HEAR.
THEY ACTED IN WAYS THAT ARE RAGE
ME AS A PERSON WHO CARES ABOUT
JUSTICE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, LET'S START
WITH THE TEAM THAT WAS APPOINTED
TO, HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY ONLY
DEMOCRATIC -- HOW DO YOU JUSTIFY
HIRING HILLARY CLINTON'S
ATTORNEY?
AND, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ENCOUNTERS LOST THEIR JOBS, AND
THAT WAS OVERTURNED BY THE FIFTH
CIRCUIT.
HOW DOES SOMEBODY LIKE THAT GET
CHOSEN IN THIS?
I HAVE A BIG PROBLEM, MR. MAYOR,
WITH THAT.
>> YOU SHOULD HAVE A BIG
PROBLEM.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS AND IT SHOULD
NOT HAPPEN AGAIN.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR BOB
MUELLER, THIS IS A FAIR GUY.
HE PICKED THE STAFF THAT HE
PICKED AND HE KIND OF LOST HIS
MIND.
YOU DON'T PICK A COUNSEL TO THE
INVESTIGATION.
ANYMORE THAN IF I WERE
INVESTIGATING HILLARY, I WOULD
PICK COUNSEL FOR THE TRUMP
FOUNDATION.
AND, WISEMAN IS PROBABLY THE
MOST NOTORIOUS PROSECUTOR YOU
CAN FIND.
HE CHARGED NONCRIMES.
HE CHARGED PEOPLE WITH THINGS
THAT ARE NOT CRIMES.
WELL, HE HAS DONE THAT IN THIS
CASE.
OBSTRUCTION, THAT'S HIS CRAZY
THEORY.
NOT A LEGITIMATE THEORY, AND THE
PROSECUTION OF COHEN WITH
CAMPAIGN FRAUD.
>> Sean: LAST QUICK QUESTION,
AND BY THE WAY NOBODY THAT
SHOULD BE QUESTIONING -- I KNOW
YOUR LEGAL BACKGROUND.
YOU ARE IN THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK, AND YOU HAVE
PROSECUTED SOME OF THE TOUGHEST
MOB GUYS IN THE COUNTRY.
WHY WAIVE EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE?
WHY WOULDN'T -- I DON'T THINK
THAT SHOULD HAPPEN, MAYBE I HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
>> IF THERE IS ANY KIND OF
PRIVILEGE IS ASSERTED, IT WILL
BE, ONCE THERE, WHAT'S THERE?
I CAN'T GIVE EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE, I CAN ONLY GIVE YOU
THE OPINION OF THIS PRIVATE
LAWYER.
I DON'T CARE WHAT THEY PUT OUT.
HE DIDN'T COLLUDE TO, AND HE
DIDN'T OBSTRUCT.
AND I CAN PROVE IT.
SO GIVE ME WHAT YOU GOT AND I
WILL KNOCK IT OUT OF THE
BALLPARK.
THAT'S THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: 87 PAGES, YOUR
REPORT, I WANT TO SEE IT.
>> I HOPE I DON'T HAVE TO USE
EIGHT.
HE DIDN'T COLLUDE TO, I DIDN'T
OBSTRUCT.
IF GROW UP GUYS, IT'S LIKE
GETTING USED TO THE FACT HE GOT
ELECTED.
CALM DOWN AND ADJUST TO THE REAL
WORLD.
>> Sean: I WANT TO SEE THAT
AND I WANT TO SEE THE PHIS